[Music]
diablo 4 is the next generation of
action rpg
melding monster slaying and loot
collecting with a fully realized open
world
it's not for the faint of heart
it's gory and unnerving
it's creepy
diablo 4 is all about player choice
it takes all of the pillars of the
diablo game and just expands them
with all the new features that people
really love and appreciate in modern
games
whoever you see yourself being you can
create in diablo for
it's important to include robust
character customization because then i
can play the fantasy that i want to play
it allows you to
switch around your playstyle as well
everything feels very powerful and fun
one of the really cool things about
having an open world is your journey
that you take throughout diablo 4 is
your own
there's no linear path that you have to
follow
we've got almost 150 dungeons in the
game
there's all kinds of surprises as you're
exploring
strongholds are an enemy territory that
you need to reclaim
you might have a space that begins as a
hostile area
but after you've cleared it out the evil
in this place has been cleansed it now
becomes a friendly town
sometimes it's a new town sometimes it's
a new dungeon
there's a whole bunch of rewards that
you get and you have a real impact on
the world as a result
no you can't leave us here they might
come back any moment local events are a
really cool little story segments that
happen within the open world you'll just
be running through the world and then a
local event will pop up and you can
choose to participate in it
or get a group together and just wail on
these like giant world bosses
these are events that take a lot of
people and you really have to work
together
being able to see all the players on
your screen collaborating trying to take
this big monster down it's it's epic
it's so easy to create a community it
makes diablo more of a social experience
we've got fully enabled cross play
if you have an xbox and your buddy has a
pc you're going to be able to group up
or you can play couch co-op two people
on a couch can sit there and have a
great experience
created specific zones where players can
engage in pvp
if you go there you can start swinging
away at people
but you're also opening yourself up to
being swung at
if you're like really really good the
game actually marks you as like a
champion on the map
you basically become a loot pinata and
everyone wants to chase you down
the last story mission is really the
beginning of a whole different part of
the journey
now you're set up for the end game and
that end game is rich with things to do
that allow you to get more and more
powerful whether it's new items or new
dungeons or new paragon boards every
single time you come back to play diablo
4 there's going to be new stuff for you
to experience
and it's something we're going to
support for years to come
i'm really excited for folks to get
their hands on diablo 4.
just to see millions of people really
enjoying the different options through
the campaign local events couch co-op or
end game pvp
it almost doesn't end
and we are so close
you